WITH THE CEO OF BLISTERITOS,
A COMPANY UNDER FIRE.
BLISTERITOS IS IN NEED
OF A MAKEOVER.
- I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CLASS-ACTION LAWSUIT.
- I KNOW.
CONGRATULATIONS.
- NO, IT'S BAD.
- OH.
- IT'S REALLY BAD.
DUE TO BLISTERITOS
CAUSING FACIAL
AND HEAD DAMAGE
TO EVERYONE
WHO EATS IT,
VOLCANO HEAD.
- I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING
ON, LIKE,
A NEGATIVE SIDE OF THINGS,
AND, LIKE,
LET'S LOOK AT THE POSITIVE
ASPECT OF YOUR PRODUCT.
- OKAY.
- THIS IS, LIKE,
A HEALTHY PRODUCT,
AND IT'S, LIKE, DELICIOUS.
- MM-HMM.
- IT IS NOT HEALTHY.
I CAN'T SAY IF IT'S DELICIOUS.
I'VE NEVER EATEN IT.
- YEAH, BUT, LIKE, ANY PRESS
IS GOOD PRESS.
- NO, THIS IS
UNANIMOUSLY TERRIBLE PRESS.
- REALLY?
- OH, IT'S BAD.
- SO THE HEADS GOT,
LIKE, RUINED?
- 400 FATALITIES.
- WOW.
- THAT'S IT?
HOW ABOUT WE JUST, LIKE,
DIG INTO SOME IDEAS?
- LOVE IT.
- HOW DOES THAT SOUND?
LIKE, 'CAUSE, LIKE, WE PUT
TOGETHER A BINDER
WITH THE NAME
OF OUR COMPANY ON IT.
IT'S, LIKE, NOT A BIG DEAL.
OKAY, HERE'S THE IDEA.
IT'S CALLED THE BLISTERITOS BUS,
AND WE SEND IT
TO THE INNER CITY.
LIKE, THAT'S WHERE, LIKE,
THE BLACK KIDS ARE
WHOSE FACES HAVE ALL BEEN
[bleep] UP BY BLISTERITOS.
- I DON'T THINK WE WANT SHOW
A LOT OF THE KIDS
WITH THE VOLCANO HEADS.
WE TRIED THAT IN A CAMPAIGN.
PEOPLE HATED SEEING THEM.
- FYI, LIKE, IN COLLEGE
MY NICKNAME WAS,
LIKE, VOLCANO HEAD.
BECAUSE, LIKE,
I WOULD SUCK GUYS OFF,
AND THEIR--WELL,
THEY WOULD JUST ERUPT.
- GREAT.
WE SHOULD GO OUT SOMETIME.
- OH, MY GOD.
- AM I, LIKE, STROKING OUT
RIGHT NOW?
WHEN I FIRST MET TRAV,
I WAS, LIKE, REPULSED BY HIM,
BUT, LIKE, AS HE BECAME
MORE INTERESTED IN LIZ,
I WAS LIKE, "THIS GUY'S
ACTUALLY GORGEOUS."
- WE REALLY NEED
TO JUST SEEM FUN.
BLISTERITOS ARE FUN.
THEY DON'T KILL CHILDREN.
- RIGHT. OOH, WE COULD DO, LIKE,
AN APP THAT COUNTS,
LIKE, THE DEATHS.